we actually have other news related to
Brett Kavanaugh as well a lot of Brett
Cavanaugh stuff today so we talked about
the background earlier just now about
sexual assault allegations against Brett
Kavanaugh we had Christine Blasi Ford
come forward allegations from high
school we had Deborah Ramirez come
forward allegations from college about
forcing his penis into her face and and
forcing her to touch it without consent
we now have learned about an individual
named James Roche James Roche was Brett
Cavanaugh's roommate at Yale in 1983
during the time that the Deborah Ramirez
incident allegedly took place and James
Roche has now given an interview and put
out a statement and what James wrote
says is not good for Cavanaugh he says
quote basically that he believes the
accuser saying quote we shared a
two-bedroom unit in the basement of
Lawrence Hall on the old campus despite
our living conditions Brett and I did
not socialize beyond the first few days
of freshman year we talked at night as
freshman roommates do and I would see
him as he returned from nights out with
his friends going on to say it is from
this experience that I concluded that
although Brett was normally reserved he
was a notably heavy drinker even by the
standards of the time meaning college
freshman in this this in the early 80s
and that he became aggressive and
belligerent when he was very drunk I did
not observe the specific incident in
question but I do remember Brett
frequently drinking excessively and
becoming in coherently drunk this is
important because Cavanaugh denies
drinking to this degree now as far as
the accuser Debbie Ramirez
James Roach again this is Cavanaugh's
college roommate went on the record and
in a statement said quote she stood out
as being exceptionally honest with a
trusting manner as we got to know one
another
I discovered that Debbie was very
worried about fitting in she felt that
everyone at Yale was very rich very
smart and very sophisticated and that as
a Puerto Rican woman from a less
privileged background she was an
outsider
her response was to try hard to make
friends and get along how could it be
that so many people are now saying that
Brett Kavanaugh either did certain
things or is exactly the type of guy who
have done certain things when he had 65
girls who knew him in high school who
said he's just a great guy now he did go
to an all-boys Catholic school it's
weird to me that 65 girls knew him well
enough to make statements on the record
about exactly what kind of a guy he was
that's a little bit odd but we can skip
over that right now because I want to
sort of circle all of this stuff Pat
back to something that is really
important that has been forgotten
because of all of these sexual assault
allegations which are important the
story about his tens or hundreds of
thousands of dollars of debt related to
baseball tickets is still out there and
it's really a concerning situation I
forgot all about that stuff it feels
like it happened ages ago the story is
important and I don't want you to let
the sketchy debt story go away because
of the sexual assault stories I don't
want the sexual assault stories to be
ignored because of the perjury stuff but
the sexual assault can be more easily
shrugged off by Republicans by saying as
they will accusers sometimes lie it's
been a long time these are smears it's a
smear campaign the $200,000 in sketchy
baseball ticket debt can't be explained
away as easily and it's also a much more
complicated story to figure out what it
is that Brett Kavanaugh actually was
doing it is extraordinarily shady but
almost nobody's talking about it anymore
and if you've forgotten about this or
never knew about it to begin with
Brett Kavanaugh had a bunch of debt that
was sort of mysteriously and very
quickly paid off in advance of his 2017
financial disclosure his claim is that
he was buying baseball tickets for
friends on his credit cards and that
then his friends would pay him back and
that he had racked up a ton of debt on
the credit cards but he was paid back lo
and behold by the time he filed this
2017 financial disclosure the debt was
completely gone but does that really
make sense to anybody because it's very
weird that a guy who is not rich at the
time based on his net worth it doesn't
really make sense that he'd be amassing
these tens of thousands of dollars
a rolling basis adding up to a couple
hundred thousand dollars in credit card
debt reportedly for baseball tickets and
then it all goes away and we don't know
how and it just absolutely stinks and
it's the sexual-assault stuff is
important if he perjured himself it's
important but there's been no reasonable
explanation for this debt being paid off
either yeah and there were plenty of
other judges conservative judges that
Trump could have picked and I wonder if
you know the sexual assault allegations
and maybe to a lesser extent the
baseball ticket stuff will be a reason
for Senate Republicans to pull the plug
on Kavanagh sometime soon and rush
through someone else I don't think it's
their call see that's the thing
the what the Republicans seem to be
doing is trying to move full speed ahead
senator corn and put out a statement
yesterday saying that if nothing new
comes from Thursday's hearing they're
gonna vote on Cavanaugh Cavanaugh in
committee and in the chamber before
adjourn in Friday that's like three days
from now so I think that as long as
Trump doesn't say we've got to pull them
as long as Cavanaugh doesn't say I'm
gonna go away because it's becoming a
distraction I think the Republicans are
sort of committed to just trying to get
him through and I think for them part of
it is they don't want it's horrible that
it's become this toxic but if they don't
get Cavanaugh through they won't see it
as this was a bad guy who lied had very
weird debts that were paid off suddenly
and had multiple sexual assault
accusations against them they will say
the Dems won they prevented us from
appointing this guy they get a win we
get a loss even though you shouldn't
want an alleged serial sex assault or on
the Supreme Court so I think that if if
no one else pulls the plug Republicans
are going for it yeah there are some
political pundits saying that if
Cavanaugh is rushed through despite all
of these allegations not getting heard
yeah then he will always have an
asterisk next to his name as a Supreme
Court justice what does that matter in
the end I mean he's going to be able to
serve on the court for what 30 40 years
and that this stuff's not going to
matter it's not going to affect his
decision made only a lifetime
appointment Pat what are you worried
about now I do have to bring this up
because the audience will crush me if I
don't did you say astrick I was thinking
about
how to pronounce this word ahead of time
and I still couldn't get it right so
yeah if you want to slam me on that it's
fair game and there's actually one more
did you say pundants
did I think I said ponded okay let's
let's play back the tape yeah let's do
it over let's roll it back do the entire
story over and cut that out we'll do an
overdub after we go to commercial make
sure you're following the show on
instagram at david pakman show make sure
you were following me on instagram at
david pakman you know who joins me next
this is someone I've been looking
forward to interviewing for a long time
you said we've been working on it since
April since April of 2018 astronaut I
guess I have to say retired astronaut
scott kelly is going to join me he spent
a year on the International Space
Station he has a twin brother Mark Kelly
who is of course the husband of former
Congresswoman Gabby Giffords who was
tragically shot in that incident several
years ago now Scott Kelly is going to
join me next I hope you will stay with
us for this one even those of you who
don't love the interviews because I'm
really looking forward to it and I hope
you are as well quick break back after
this today's program is sponsored in
part by blinka comm slash Pakman if
you've not already heard about blink
Asst it's amazing it's an app for your
phone tablet or web browser and what
they do is they take nonfiction books
popular nonfiction critically acclaimed
nonfiction they condense the book into a
15 minute audio book you get all the
most important information and insights
from each book but you can soak up the
entire essence of the book in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK
is t.com /pa que ma n